Hi everyone.
I'm going to travel to 12 cities in the
US,
Canada,
and the UK in the next few months to
speak about my book,
12 rules for life and other related
issues.
First,
I'll be in New York at the beacon
theater at the end of March.
All announced the precise date.
In the next few days,
I'll be going to the other 11 cities in
May.
All announced those dates very soon to
those cities include Toronto,
Washington,
Chicago,
Detroit,
Denver,
San Francisco,
Seattle,
London,
Austin,
Dallas,
and Phoenix.
Tickets will be available for Presale
February 21st if you go to my website,
Jordan b peterson.com and subscribe to
the mailing list at the bottom of the
page,
you can register for presale
notification.
There's also an
eventsPage@jordanbpeterson.com tickets
will go on sale for everyone on February
23rd hope to see you at one of those
venues.
Thanks very much for the continued
support and interest.
Bye Bye.